I don't know what I'm going to talk to
them about if somebody says we're going
to decapitate you what will I talk about
the method of our decapitation we're
going to destroy you the method of our
destruction I mean Iran is openly
committed to destroying
the
repeating the Holocaust and destroying
the six or seven million Jews of Israel
and we're not going to sit by idly by
and let them do it and also I don't
think that diplomacy by itself will work
I think diplomacy can only work if you
it's coupled with
um
with a credible military threat or the
willingness to apply that the military
option if the turns fails we've delayed
them by actions that among other things
that I authorized in my terms of
government but while we set them back at
least 10 years we didn't stop them and
they're progressively moving forward and
that's the danger we'll do whatever we
need to do to defend to defend ourselves
but I'm not going to get into any
greater detail